What is up developers? Welcome back to
GitHub awesome. GitHub trending today
episode 31. 36 repositories trending on
GitHub right now. Let's get into it.
Every browserbased terminal renders onto
an HTML canvas. That means no native
text selection. Werm reimagines the web
terminal entirely. Built with Zigg and
Web Assembly, it parses VT100 and Xterm
escape sequences, but renders output
directly into the DOM as real semantic
HTML text. Native text selection,
perfect copy, paste, and screen reader
support out of the box. The entire WASM
core is 12 kilob. React support
included.
Someone built a palunteer style
operations dashboard to coordinate three
families driving to Yusede. convoy
routes, arrival windows, mission launch
overlays, meal logistics, a live Google
Maps layer with day-by-day timeline
playback for a cabin trip. The readme
describes it as intentionally overbuilt
for a small real life use case. React
19, vit framer motion runs locally in a
few commands.
Duck DB is the best local analytical
database available, but scaling it to a
team usually means paying for mother
duck. OpenDuck is a self-hosted
re-implementation of Motherduck's core
architectural ideas. Dual execution and
differential storage on your own
infrastructure. SQL queries executing
across both local and remote
simultaneously. Heavy lifting pushed to
the cloud while local results stay
instant.
The hard drive died into its activation
servers have been offline since 2017.
The $199 license is worthless, so they
rebuilt it from scratch. Slowbooks is a
full double entry bookkeeping app with
invoices, estimates, payments, bank
reconciliation, P&L, balance sheet, and
AR aging. Authentic QuickBooks 2003 Navy
and gold skin reads and writes IIF files
so data round trips with QB203 if you
still have it running. Someone was
spending over $200 a day on clawed code
API credits with no idea where it was
going. So, they built a tool to find
out. Code burn is a terminal UI that
reads your local session transcripts and
categorizes every token spent. No LLM
calls required. Cost broken down by task
type, debugging, brainstorming, actual
coding, plus token overhead from bloated
MCP servers. Interactive daily activity
chart and a Mac menu bar widget
included.
Building beautiful interactive terminal
interfaces means cobbling together
dozens of raw npm packages. Term CNN
brings the Shad/ UI philosophy directly
to the terminal. Built on Ink, it's a
registry of over 100 zeroconfig terminal
UI components you copy and paste into
your React codebase, command pallets,
progress bars, interactive charts,
sidebars, and specialized AI components
like streaming text and thinking blocks.
Sideloading apps on iOS used to mean
Apple's desktop software or keeping Alt
server running 24/7 on a Mac or PC. Side
Impactor ports the entire cryptographic
signing process into clientside
JavaScript via the web USB API. Use it
on a Windows machine at a library, a
Linux laptop, or Chrome on an Android
phone. Sign and inject an IPA directly
into your iPhone from any browser.
Cloning a massive repository just to
read a few files is wasteful and slow.
GHFS uses Apple's native file system
extensions to mount GitHub repositories
directly to Finder as a virtual readonly
file system. Browse remote repos like
regular folders, open files straight in
VS Code or Xcode. Zero disk space used
until you actually open something. No
git clone, no web interface, no messy
history to manage.
Animated handwriting effects on landing
pages usually mean hours of manually
tracing SVG paths in Illustrator. Tagi
automates the entire process. Give it
any Google font and it generates a
perfectly animated real-time handwriting
effect. The creator wrote a complete
image processing pipeline including
custom rasterization and distance
transforms single npm package react
components included.
Zada just open sourced the platform
powering their cloud service. The
standout feature is copyon write
branching at the storage level. A
terabyte Postgress database branches in
seconds making preview environments and
test setups that were previously
impractical suddenly cheap. Runs on
Kubernetes built on cloudnative PG and
open EBS. Scale to zero baked in.
Inactivity hibernates the instance.
First connection wakes it back up.
Weft is a new programming language where
LLMs, APIs, databases, and human in the
loop approvals are base language
primitives the same way integers and
loops are in Python. It compiles to Rust
and runs on restate so your code can
literally pause midf function. Send a
form to a human, wait 3 days for
approval, and execution resumes exactly
where it left off. No web hooks, no
cues, no state machines.
You've seen those glowing border
animations on Versel and linear pricing
cards. Border beam makes it a single
component. Give your container relative
positioning. Drop in the tag and you
instantly get a glowing beam tracing the
perimeter. Customizable colors, beam
size, animation duration, and multiple
delayed beams for a sci-fi tracing
effect. Works with Nex.js, Vite, and
Remix. Out of the box, design extract
takes a URL, crawls the live DOM, and
reverse engineers the entire design
language. Colors, fonts, grid patterns,
hover transitions, responsive
breakpoints, outputs a Tailwind config,
CSS variables, a shad CN UI theme, and
Figma variables. Install the output as a
cloud code skill. Type
extractdesignstripe.com,
and your agent builds a landing page
matching that exact design system first
try.
Docker file roast is an opinionated
Docker file llinter written in Rust that
doesn't give you boring warnings. It
aggressively roasts your bad DevOps
practices. Layer bloat, missing cache
mounts, running as root, uncombbined run
commands, all called out with exactly
how to fix them. Drop it in CI and let
it automatically roast your teammates's
unoptimized pull requests in the code
comments.
App Store screenshots are one of those
launch tasks that takes far longer than
it should. SnapFrame wraps your raw
screenshots in device frames, applies
color themes, and exports correctly
sized assets for every app store and
Play Store resolution entirely in the
browser with no uploads or login
required. Feed your app metadata to an
LLM, get a layout config back, and your
entire marketing screenshot suite
generates in one click.
Port Paul is a lightweight Tori and Rust
desktop app that shows every active port
on your machine, detects which specific
project is using it, and lets you kill
zombie processes with one click. No
terminal required. Live port map
visualization shows how your front end,
API, and database connect in real time.
Sits in your menu bar with a traffic
light status icon. Clone any voice from
a 3-se secondond audio clip, translate
it into dozens of languages, and dub it
back into your video automatically.
OmniVoice Studio is a fully open-source
dubbing and voice generation platform.
It transcribes, translates, clones the
voice, isolates vocals to preserve
background music and sound effects, and
adapts to the speaker's native accent,
timber, and pacing.
Electron text editors eat RAM, drain
your battery, and take forever to boot.
LightEeddit is a native Mac OS code
editor built purely in Swift and AppKit.
The entire app is 1 megabyte. Full
syntax highlighting, interactive file
tree sidebar, boots instantly. No
Electron, no bloat, just a pure Apple
native editing experience that stays out
of your way.
Carpathy's AI maintained wiki concept
was powerful, but required wrestling
with Python scripts and terminal
environments. Wiki Wise packages the
entire concept into a native Mac OS app.
Zero coding, zero configuration.
Built-in Swifterm terminal lets you run
claude code or codecs directly inside.
File manager, AI terminal, and live
markdown preview all side by side.
Writing text prompts for complex
multi-step web workflows is frustrating.
Video use lets you show instead of tell.
Record your screen, click through the
website yourself, and it uses computer
vision to extract your mouse movements,
clicks, and keystrokes, converting the
recording directly into a fully
executable AI workflow. No code, no
step-by-step instructions. Just do the
task once, and the AI learns it. Just
open your terminal and type SSH late.sh.
Your SSH key is your identity. Late.sh
SH is a multiplayer clubhouse for
developers built entirely in Rust with
Ratatouille. Chat with developers
globally. Grow a virtual bonsai tree
that withers if you break your streak.
Play Tetris, Mind Sweeper, chess, and
Texas Holden Poker, a synchronized
global loafy music radio with a realtime
ASI audio visualizer that syncs to the
beat in your terminal.
Getting fast local LLM generation
usually means quantizing your model
until it gets dumb. DFlash MLX fixes
that without sacrificing quality. It
brings lossless speculative decoding to
Apple silicon via MLX. A tiny draft
model uses block diffusion to propose 16
tokens at once. Then your full target
model verifies the entire block in a
single forward pass. Output is bit
forbit identical to normal generation.
Bunwv is a 400line CLI tool that runs as
a persistent headless browser demon on
Mac. Zero dependencies. It hooks
directly into native WebKit. Commands
dispatch as OS level native events. So
the browser registers them as is
trusted. True. Completely
indistinguishable from a real human.
Persistent over a Unix socket. So your
agent logs in, goes off and does other
tasks, comes back later, and the session
DOM state and O are all still there.
Commercial Mac cleaners have a giant
clean button and you just blindly trust
them. If something breaks, it's gone
permanently.
Maxif takes the opposite approach. It
lists every junk file, log, and cache
grouped by the exact app that owns it.
Full transparency before anything
happens. Maxift never permanently
deletes files. Everything moves to your
trash so you can restore anything
instantly if an app breaks.
Nano FFmpeg is a keyboard-driven TUI
built-in Go that wraps FFmpeg into a
clean dashboard. Browse files with arrow
keys. Pick from 12 guided operations and
it handles the rest. Autodetects
hardware acceleration like video toolbox
and envank suggests smart defaults from
your media file. Live command preview
shows you the exact raw ffmpeg command
before you execute. So you actually
learn the tool instead of just hiding it
behind a UI. Getting remote desktop
access to a Windows machine usually
means fighting firewalls, opening
inbound ports, or managing separate VPN
clients. Tail VNC bundles a fully
functional VNC server and an embedded
Tailcale node into one standalone
Windows binary. Drop it on the target
machine and it punches through NATS and
firewalls to connect directly into your
WireGuard encrypted tail scale network.
Video editing means sifting through
hours of raw footage to find the perfect
3-second clip. This tool automates the
entire pipeline. A Gentic video editor
takes a folder of raw footage and a text
brief and produces a polished MP4 using
an ensemble of AI agents. A director
selects the best shots. A trim refiner
tightens the cuts. An editor renders the
timeline.
Every developer knows how to call an LLM
API. Very few actually understand what's
running underneath. LLM internals breaks
down the entire AI pipeline in plain
English. Tokenization, self-attention
mechanics, inference optimization on
real hardware, no dense academic papers,
no terrifying math formulas, clean
developer friendly explanations with
code snippets showing exactly how text
turns into intelligent predictions.
Interacting with your Hermes AI agent
usually means sitting at a terminal.
Hermes-Tlegram-
miniapp bridges Hermes directly into
Telegram as a native mini app. Not a
basic chat bubble. A full terminal style
UI rendered inside your messaging app.
Aski banner, real-time spinners, skills
panel, cron jobs, system monitoring,
stats, all of it. It feels like sshing
directly into your autonomous AI agent
from your pocket.
The iPhone's dynamic island, but on your
Mac desktop. Super Island is a fully
extensible floating notch for Mac OS, a
local HTTP endpoint that lets you pipe
notifications from anywhere directly
into it. Developers are hooking it up to
clawed code so when an agent finishes a
refactor, hits an error, or needs human
approval, it pops a sleek interactive
notification into the dynamic island
instead of getting buried in terminal
output.
Can it run Doom? This developer took
that question to the network layer. Curl
Doom is an HTTP server that renders live
Doom frames as antsy halfblock
characters and streams them to your
terminal over a standard web request.
Type one curl command and you're playing
Doom. Birectional streaming captures
your keystrokes and pushes updated ASKI
frames back in real time.
A raw linear scan of 100,000 vectors on
S3 takes 25 seconds per query. Fernflow
brings that down to 72 micros on warm
queries. That's a 350,000x difference.
And every cache hit means zero S3
requests on your bill. Three tier cache,
RAM, NVMe, then S3. Multi-tenant by
design with per namespace S3 prefixes.
Vector search, BM25 full text, and
hybrid all supported.
Local LLM generation on Apple silicon,
but four times faster without
sacrificing quality. Dlash MLX brings
speculative decoding to Apple's MLX
framework. A tiny draft model uses block
diffusion to predict 16 tokens at once
in parallel. Then your full target model
verifies the entire block in a single
forward pass. A custom metal kernel
handles tape replay roll back so every
token is perfectly verified before being
committed.
Obscura is a headless browser written in
Rust that drops the Chromium UI
entirely, but embeds the actual V8
engine for real JavaScript execution.
Native Chrome DevTools protocol support
makes it a drop-in replacement for
existing Puppeteer and Playwright
scripts. 30 megabytes of RAM, instant
startup, 85 millisecond page loads
versus half a second for standard
headless Chrome.
Mac OS Synoma lets you click your
desktop wallpaper to instantly clear all
your windows. Windows doesn't have this.
So Scott Hansselman, legendary Microsoft
engineer, just built and open sourced it
for Windows 10 and 11. Peak Desktop is a
single file utility that runs in your
system tray. Click empty wallpaper. All
Windows Minimize instantly. Click
anything to restore your workspace.
Type a prompt. Get a back tested trading
strategy.
Vibe Trading is a multi-agent finance
workspace. 69 specialized finance skills
and 29 preconfigured agent swarm teams.
Spin up a virtual global equities desk
where a crypto analyst and a global
strategist debate the market before
delivering a final investment call.
Exposes everything as an MCP plug-in so
Claude Desktop can gather market data
and write trading algorithms.